ich teste die viralen instant Mayo
Rahmen dafür brauchen wir natürlich Mayo
außerdem habe ich noch frühlingswiebel
natürlich die rahmennudeln aus so einem
Paket mit den beiden Gewürzmischung und
zwei Eier ein Ei werde ich kochen dann
fangen wir schon mal an wir machen jetzt
in einer kleinen Schüssel in der wir
auch später die Rahmen servieren unsere
Mayo hinein dann unsere Soße und jetzt
brauchen wir auch schon unser zweites Ei
davon brauchen wir nur das Eigelb und
dann können wir auch schon anfangen zu
verquirlen dann geben wir auch schon
unsere Nudeln in den Topf so dann können
wir jetzt auch schon anfangen
Nudelwasser zu unserer soßenbasis
hinzuugeben und das ganze einzurühren
boah schnell das so richtig trüb wird ne
dann holen wir die Nudeln raus und geben
sie in die Brühe was ich auch auf tiktok
gesehen habe ist dass Leute einfach so
eine Scheibe Käse on top legen dann
mache ich jetzt mein Ei hier auf
wunderbar dann toppe ich das ganze noch
mit ein bisschen Frühlingszwiebel noch
zwei Nori Blätter rein so jetzt wollen
wir mal sehen wie die schmecken creamy
sind sie auf jeden Fall Alter richtig
schön cremig die Soße hat richtigen
Punch gehabt die ich dabei hatte für die
kurze Zeit die man investiert wirklich
ein sehr sehr heftiges Produkt